hello I am Ricardo Giglio and I will be
speaking about wool from my bench in for
Python
hello everybody I'm Ricardo and we are
gonna talk about Wolfram web engine for
Python so what is what from web engine
for Python this is a new open source
library people are still getting in okay
so what from where budget for Python is
a open source library that is available
already on github and allows you to
develop and publish web application
locally using word from language so this
library can be used with any kind of war
from kernel including the one that comes
with Mathematica twelve to one point one
but also with the new free world from
engine for developers that allows you to
create and develop applications for free
and you can use this system in order to
create application entirely using more
firm language or you can incrementally
update existing application that you
already have in Python and so during
this talk we will see how to do that how
to create from from scratch and new
application and how to increment a new
Python an existing party application the
one will be C will be a Django
application and we also show how to take
existing word from language code that
works on the Wolfram cloud and just take
this code and see how it works on your
local machine and at the end of the tour
K will explain differences with n
advantages with using the public cloud
when should you will use that and which
you should use the system ok so let's
get started here there are some links to
go on get up
like I'm get up there is the
documentation for warfarin web engine
and all the options and so if you want
you can go ahead and take a look at the
documentation what you need to do is
just to have Python 3 installed on your
machine and then just because this is a
Python 3 only library and just go ahead
and and pip install well from my bench
in that will take care of installing all
the dependencies
under God you need to get started and
then there is also like a link here for
a word from client for Python which is a
library that I was presenting against
when years ago here with another
colleague Dorian that that is basically
a library that allows you to do to
evaluate Wolfram language code using an
external evaluator or a logger evaluate
or already in Python so let's take a
look how it works the high-level
perspective this is just we are using a
Python framework that is called a Oh
HTTP which is a very modern framework
implemented in Python 3 doing heavy use
of coroutines and I think
functionalities and within this
framework you can specify web pages but
also any kind of other contents PDF what
whatever
dynamic content you want to serve and
you can use standard word from language
function such as a be a function for
function for page URL dispatcher those
are all documented function that you
find in our internal documentation and
and all this function they just work
seamlessly with a with this framer so I
cannot stress enough that this software
is open-source and the nice thing is
that is built on very solid foundation I
think because a HTTP is a production
server that has been around for years
and it's very fast and efficient and
well used and also the client libraries
is getting very mature because we
presented it two years ago I think and
during the last year we have done a lot
of improvements so external evaluate
between twelve and twenty point one just
got a performance boost that is
something around three hundred four
hundred percent for normal use cases and
this is done because we have made a lot
of improvement in data transfer in C
realizing numeric arrays and things like
that
so when you're using this library all
the performance improvements that we
have done when word from client library
are here for free so once you you
basically just need to start a new
terminal session and do pip install or
from web engine this is already done on
my machine and what you need to do here
is just to start the demo by running
this command the the server would start
it says that it's available on this
location so we can just go I had an open
the browser and we should see the demo
application running on my machine so
this is just one function it's very
simple application let's see if this is
actually working so we we just take an
image from my downloads whatever and
then we the second is to just apply fist
so that what what this one function is
doing is just what I filter to the image
and return the image so we just run it
and we got the filter applied to the
machine to the to the image so this
worked fantastic we can try to do
something real now we can within this
framework where we let you build an
application using two different system
so one is to use a single file with the
URL dispatcher and another one is to use
multiple files in a directory layout so
let's start with the first one the first
one is something that is so URL
dispatcher is a function that is
documented in word from language that is
just a URL router this concept should be
familiar for people that are doing
modern web development so all a lot of
Python frameworks like Django twister
tornado they all work like that so they
just have a specification of URL pad and
a function that is executed when the URL
part is visited by the user browser and
so in this case on the left hand side we
have some URL path on the right hand
side an expression and needs to be
executed when the user goes on that part
so we can basically evaluate this code
and create this file on my machine we
can take a look who what's inside this
guy with normal text editor so this is
just what from language input form code
that you that that I have on this file
now I use the same crew that I was using
before but instead of running the demo I
just put in the path to that file now I
open the browser again and I see hello
world which is what was expected because
we were specifying that on the on page I
want to see hello world now again if I
go on different paths of this
application here I have a form function
and here I have an API function so nice
thing about the system is that this is
just so c-couldn't
and if I go ahead here and just change
something inside it I don't need to
restart anything again just go on this
page refers to the browser and and
changes their life so here I can have
something dynamic like a random real and
refresh the page and every time I get a
different number or I can have I don't
know like a different image every time
by doing random image in PNG format now
every time i refresh the browser I get a
different image PNG I think this was it
for a single file layout the next system
is multiple file in a directory layout
it should be more familiar for people
who are coming for more traditional web
frameworks like PHP Java servlet pages
things like that where you basically
have a directory structure on your
machine that maps directly with the the
URL path of the
and so here what I'm doing is just to
create a test application on my machine
and this is just code that is producing
a bunch of files there I can go ahead
and open it on my machine and you should
see that I have these folder structure
so if I let's inspect this for the
structure on a text editor again and
here is you can see there is just a lot
of files and folders and let's see what
is happening when I try to run this
application so I just take the folder
path this time and as before instead of
saying this path sherry I put the new
path so test up run it again now the
this is saying that is running on the
same part but or a different location
fine now i refresh the application and i
see what is happening in the home page
so there is a frameworks that are
thinking in this way there is this
convention where the the folder got an
index file and so in this case is this
index dot WS will was returning a JSON
response with the unix time whatever is
the unix time in my machine at this
moment so if updated you should see that
the number is increasing and so yeah
there are other resources here one is
response again here if I go there and
just change something all over this name
changes are live again if you have some
static content static content is
directly served so you can just go here
and study cheese and this is keeping the
governor so he served directly by the
server and again here there is a folder
and I've just go there under / API the
index file is executed and the API
function code that is inside here is
executed again and I can have yeah phone
function and whatever
so this was how to structure an
application using multiple folders on
your machine and the next one is how to
integrate an existing application so I
was saying that these framework got
bindings for some popular libraries at
the beginning at this moment we only
have two of them Django and the HTTP but
we would like to add support for more of
them so if you guys have no like
framework that you're using and you're
interesting in it you can just go ahead
and go on get up and over an issue and
maybe also if you want like start
contributing because this this framework
is really simple and easy to understand
so it's very easy to add support for
other libraries so as soon as we got
requests and other people contributing
we are we are willing to add more and
more support for existing frameworks
what we can do here is to is to show our
Django application can be can be
augmented what I will do is to just open
the source code for in the library there
are examples in there there are also
available on github bear in the red me
so under examples there is a jungle
occasion here and I don't know if you
guys are familiar with the jungle but
this is what a jungle application looks
like so again it's you define a URL
pattern that takes some request pot and
then you map a function to it a function
is just something very simple that takes
the request information like this one
and needs to return an HTTP response so
if I just run this application in the
way you're supposed to run a jungle
occation so you just do stop the other
one Python three you have a manage file
and then you do run server this is now
just starting django web server that
runs from port
eight thousand so I just go there and
see if this is working yes it's
returning the HTTP response that was
specified here but now what I arrive
also to other views that are implemented
that are using a cabinet so again if I
just go under /gi
I have an ABI function response and
under slash form oops
for functional response ology is done
this is done by importing that class war
from language session which is something
that is documented on the ward from
client and this is just an eye-level
interface to evaluate warframe language
code so you you import this evaluator
that allows you to to execute warfare
language code and there is a constructor
for Wolfram language code this is also
documented under the word from client
and you can in Python create symbolic
for foreign language code with this
syntax and then I'm just adding a
decorator to this function that says
that this function is android by the
kernel by this session and so now what
this is doing is that is taking the
genre request and asking the governor to
to return an HTTP response the nice
thing here is that this is just Python
code so here you can go ahead and say
something like if request user is
authenticated
kated something like that do something
otherwise do something else so here you
can just use your existing
authentication middleware whatever it
was and and behind that return some kind
of and ask the colonel to to return an
HTTP response so you can keep your
existing business logic and start using
word from language with few lines of
code
another interesting thing is that war
from client exposes several kind of
evaluators this is one of them that
allows you to start the colonel and and
always execute code on the same colonel
but the results are Colonel pool that is
implemented so you can just instead of
importing that guy in portage admin pool
and now you you have a cabinet pool of
four candles that are handling requests
and basically every time a request comes
in the first scanner that is available
is handling a request for you or you can
use the cloud evaluator got the same API
you can just imported and use the cloud
to do the evaluation of course there's
gonna be Network latency and so on but
you don't need to install anything
locally and will just work you just need
to provide your cloud authentication
information okay so this was how doing
basically in increment and an augment
and existing Python application and now
let's talk about the differences with
with the Wolfram cloud advantages and
disadvantages so what are the
differences here and the obviously like
the word from cloud is a is a is a big
product meaning that is able to you know
manage let's say whatever traffic you
need to manage which means that you
don't need to worry about the size of
your application you can just as any
cloud services you know you can just
deploy your single function single API
and you don't need to worry about
managing the art we're managing the
deployment anything like that this is
not the case for this and so this this
can be a disadvantage
it can also be an opportunity because
when you are installing you need to
install a wall from Colonel on your
machine so that you need to do it by
yourself but then once you do that you
know you can basically run any kind of
binary on your machine which is not
something that we allow on the public
cloud because we for security reason we
cannot allow you to run any kind of
process or or binary on a machine that I
share with other the user but to be fair
this is not a limitation of the
enterprise private cloud where you can
disable all these mechanism and you can
just shut off the security and you know
and you can start running whatever you
need to run on your machine an advantage
is that there is much faster development
and bug the bug in wheels you have seen
that you know you don't need to run and
deploy code on the cloud get back with
the response and so on you can just
execute code directly on your machine
and if you print or egg or something the
output is going to be on your terminal
so like if in the middle of the gold you
find some kind of order error you you
just print it and you get the output
directly on your own on the terminal you
can work with that another team that yes
and this is not something that that
results as you can see like as soon as
you change something on on the source
code changes are reflected in the
browser and this is not something that
you can really do for example in Python
because every time you change something
in Python it needs to restart the whole
process it needs to start all webserver
now it's not a big deal if it is a small
application it takes a fraction of a
second to restart but if it is a big
application it can takes also seconds
this just will never up and here because
in the end you just change the finish on
inside a running kernel and and and then
you can just update and changes are done
quickly and fast this is not something
that you should that you should probably
disable on production because you don't
want is auto reloading
and is more production but for
development is really it's really
effective another thing is that and I
think it's very important point is that
this is something that is very easy to
reason with meaning that this is not a
giant product and not a giant
application is built on top of a
lightweight web server a HTTP and on top
of another library that is not that big
actually for what is doing this library
the core of this libraries is around 100
200 lines of code because we managed to
leverage some high level you know
evaluators and classes that we are
exposing in world from clients so if you
take a look at the source code for this
for this framework is going to be like
super easy to read and to reason with
which means that it's great because if
there is a problem if there is a bug or
something is happening you can just go
ahead and look here to the source code
this is what is happening and you can
either open an issue for us or
contributed by yourself and just
directly fix it because really is it's
really really straightforward and I
think is also an important point like
having less mental overhead when when
when developing an application and what
is when this is a good fit I think this
is a good fit for micro service
architecture so let's say that you have
an application that is you know where
the backend is completely separated from
the front-end something like you have
the front-end Ares in JavaScript so this
big giant JavaScript application that is
interacting with with a one or more back
ends in a meager service architecture so
you can have like something in part of
something in Java and so on now you can
just you know add a word from engine and
start returning code from over from from
a wall from web server and and so you
don't need to drop your existing
back-end you don't need to do any
that you can just add something else
next to what you're ready of so you can
keep your existing business business
logic and so on and as I was saying
before like the integration with Python
allows you to to keep any kind of you
know middleware you already got in place
so if you have already on authentication
middleware you can just use it you you
you don't need to migrate to our way of
authenticating user you can just
authenticate the user before and then if
the user our identity that just returned
the API response to them and otherwise
written another response like this is
not available if blah you are not
integrated and so yeah these are
disallowed to keep you like all your
existing you know authentication logic
in one place and just start returning
and focus on you know the actual content
that you need to produce with Wolfram
language and this comes with easy to and
integrate with a with an existing
service because if you have like a
Python web server you've seen that like
with a few lines of code you can you can
just run it so yeah I think this was
kind of everything like the what what
you can also do and I will show it
quickly I forgot is that you so when you
when you start a desktop there are
several options that you can take a look
at the documentation for more from web
engine one of them and I think is worth
mentioning is this pool size and so as
you can see now this guy is starting an
application with a pool for Carol and
they are all starting here so every time
I go now to this application and i
refresh the browser each request is
going to a different kernel now you can
see like the first four aggressed are
taking a little bit much longer because
there is the kernel in it
- on time and then subsequent requests
are much faster we are in the order of
right now of seven eight milliseconds of
overhead for for requests and that
includes you know in parsing the
incoming requests transfer it to the
journal execute some code transferring
back and return it to the user which i
think is so performance is getting there
we we will keep optimizing this but I
think it's already good for for some
production application